老哥你每次講最厲害的籌碼就是關鍵分點
今天大放鬆了
關鍵分點我們有幾個SOP
哇這分點都是厲害的
現賺5萬塊一張
對
Special的
Special
好
這個是我今年給你的禮物
喔
全台灣好不好
1700檔公司的關鍵分點
直接告訴你答案
直接告訴我
對 紅馬K線這個軟體
這邊都看得很清楚
有很多人說
小哥最近太少來理台大安秀
太少來 太忙了
太忙
可是我看你都在PO吃喝玩熱啊
然後你體重你都沒有瘦
欸欸欸
因為呢
我都去各地上課
你是去上課嗎
對
我看你一下去宜蘭
一下去花蓮
等一下去台南
對啊
宜蘭花蓮比較少上課
但是真的去玩
不過台南 高雄 嘉義 彰化
台中 新竹 桃園 台北
西岸就對了
西岸都在上課
學員太多了
學員太多多少
大概一萬多人有
我的學員因為貴節目
增加很多
理財達人秀歌有仇必報
大家看了歌有仇必報之後
這個看得還不過癮
所以今天大放送
放鬆喔
講一個非常禁忌的話題
真的是禁忌喔
真的特別的
特別
好
大家有沒有超期待
歌有仇必報
跟趙華做到第19集了
我跟你講喔
小哥的太太喔
注意囉
你一定覺得趙華最近都沒在撩
對不對
因為趙華做電視節目做得好累喔
但是小哥今天被我逮到了
我們這一集非常的禁忌
非常的禁忌
怎麼禁忌法呢
大家以前都會敲碗說
小哥你每次講最厲害的籌碼
就是關鍵分點
可惜關鍵分點不能說
今天好不好
這一集拜託你會去看100遍
關鍵分點我們今天把小哥壓榨出來了
把它榨乾了
因為呢對不對
跟趙華做了19次
總要交出點貨來
沒問題
沒問題對不對
還記得我們上一集
我們有個截圖嗎
什麼截圖
我知道
你記得去我的FB看一下
該你的老二表現一下該我的老二表現一下前面是說那老大表現得很好啊老大華邦店啊我就是說交加的老二要表現一下
交加老二關我什麼事啊
我不曉得為什麼這個理財達人秀的字幕好像
這寫起來好像蠻奇怪的
該我的老二表現一下
這個我覺得把它截圖
蠻好玩的
放在粉絲團上很多讚
對比過去報的名牌準
它還更多讚
因为刚好隔天就喷了
隔天就喷了
老二表现了
你家说老二喷了
今天老三喷了
今天是老三喷
今天是华兴克长天
我们来看我们最近讲的标的
最近讲的标的
其实我们不是投顾老师
我们不是投顾老师
当然不是
我们不能代单
我们是教学节目
教你方法
我们从来不代单
这都是他们自己人品好
他们学会了
他们学会自己人品好
他们自己去研究筹码
我们会跟他们讲说
这个股票像华邦店
你就要特别注意管钱的分点
这个其实公开
我们在理财大人秀
也有教大家
讲很多次了
很难得
很难得愿意讲关键分点在哪里
因为管钱分点那很大
跟学员讲
学员有正序研究
小哥说的是对的
而且买很多
所以他們就去買
因為他們就跟著關鍵分點做
那一買之後 他們就加薪了
像這個學院賺了24萬
因為他有35口的華邦店期貨
這個學院賺了12萬
這個學院買一堆
真的很巧 跟達仁秀做集團股交加做帳
差不多時間了
因為他大概10月多就買了
所以他們很多人都抱一個波段
那抱一個波段呢
再利用期貨槓桿的特性
其實他們用很多很多人
都用小錢賺了大錢
而且上次華邦店其實有說
關鍵分點因為很早就佈局了
所以我們節目播的時候
他有一點點在逢高貨率出脫
但接下來還是連續大漲了兩三天
因為那個火車開動之後
很難停下來
華邦店是火車啊
那很大股本啊
那這個他在上面稍微調節
我剛剛看了一下
華邦店的這關鍵分點
其實囤貨還是囤很多
稍微慢一點而已
而且這樣繼續往上拉而它的個股期好處就是它可以快速的也是快速出對 而且它的量很大這個期貨的黃黃店我們有的期貨還怕流動性風險
黃黃店沒有
當然它大股本的公司全股股
他們就花個幾千塊就可以買個一口
那就慢慢的
我看到這種對阿南都替他們開心
對啊 好厲害 學得很好
這些都是靠他們自己去研究分店
你看南亞科也是
南亞科科技能分店也是大買
這個我們在交易筆記本上面
也提過很多啦
對 但是我也必須講啦
因為很多人看理財達人秀
它會很困擾一件事情
小哥都秀的關鍵分點啊
第一 我哪知道誰是關鍵分點
第二 我哪怎麼統計關鍵分點
小哥要是沒講到我的股票
我就不知道了
對 所以他們需要的是工具
對 然後所以呢
你知道每次我們節目一播出
下面就說
小哥你幫我看這一家關鍵分點
小哥你幫我看這個B股票的關鍵分點
沒辦法這樣應付
服務院都是要自己學的
而且也不能公開啦
也不能公開
有些公開之後他就真的搬家了
可是今天不行
今天要公開一些
然後再來就是現在這個時間點
因為我們節目公開也講過嘛
就是說年底
對其實是作帳最強的時刻
我們如果不撈這一波
真的是很可惜
對 很可惜
每年12月最好賺
而且搞不好比那種
3月19號上來都還好賺
對啊 這裡都噴翻了
什麼聯電 華邦電
這以前都是很牛的股票
長榮 哇 那麼牛
我們家要王寶川股
苦手含瑶18年才賺
所以都非常強
那為什麼年底最好賺呢
給各位看一下
第一個集團作賬
對啊 真的 焦師傅
焦師傅
真的厲害 很厲害
所以很多個師傅都很厲害
連郭師傅都可以賺
郭師傅 黃師傅 焦師傅 陳師傅
好幾個師傅都很厲害
大家自己對號入座
第二個呢 財報空窗
對 已經進入空窗期了
明年3月我才知道
對啊 我現在要怎麼喊都可以
好壞喔 現在都不用負責任的
不負責任 對
第三個呢 我們最近發現很多關鍵分點都大買喔
你的意思是本來可能10月11月還好
12月了一堆關鍵分點覺得
哎呀 該我表現啦
對啊
所以關鍵分點在12月很活絡
很活絡
舉例來說
來吧 我們來看這個焦師傅的這個你有透露過因為他們的媳婦有元大的人嘛對对元大的人送分题我们今天这个把两个都合在一起
那就是关键分点
好
同一个分点买在前面
我们来看像这个同一个管钱分点
华欣
各位看到他买在这里
好
后面喷出
华欣
大牛股
不锈钢股
对
那这个华邦店买在这边
这就厉害了
这就是一千张一千张买
這天是2萬張
後面噴出喔
彩晶呢
哇它買在這裡
後面就馬上噴出喔
彩晶它算很有毅力的喔
面板股其實它的籌碼
現在看起來最厲害了
沒錯沒錯
所以這個我們之前有講過
有取了元大的媳婦
然後也懶得換地方了
就在車水馬龍的管前
東森的旁邊
所以它的關鍵分點就是
元差管前
好
沒問題
不要答錯答案
我猜焦師傅也不會再搬家了
不會啦,又不會換媳婦
欸,這不一定
但是做了那麼多年都在這裡
這可信度很高
對,而且他不怕你知道
對
讓你知道又怎麼樣
我們就是要做啊
全世界都知道我教師傅會集團做自己
對啊,不然這樣
對啊
請教師傅來上電視好了
好,那這些其實我們利用
這個籌碼K線裡面
這個手機版
手機版就有了嗎?
對,我們今天特別來看這個手機板
哇,今天華心科
因為這個就是剛剛趙華講的啦
關鍵分點其實如果你沒有任何的軟體
坦白說撈不出來
坦白說不知道
所以趙華必須講
有時候小哥講的東西
你也沒有辦法等嘛
你手上1700多檔股票
你要自己做功課
說實話沒有軟體做不到
對,這個坦白說
所以現在手機有個APP就對了
手機APP,這是籌碼黑線的APP
籌碼黑線,小哥其實一直都是用籌碼黑線
一直很好用啊
目前台灣在做籌碼上面
這個公司算是最厲害的
我們來看像華邦店
華邦店我們看他的籌碼
籌碼日報
例如說我看這60天來
60天來我們剛剛講的那個管錢
元大管錢
他買了三萬一千多張
雖然他有做稍微調節一點
小賣一點
不過這台車已經被他開動了
不容易停下來
所以千萬不要去放空喔
沒坐多到不要空頭
沒搭上車就算了 不要放空
除了滑板店以外 像最近
彩晶啊
彩晶我們剛剛也就有講
彩晶的這個關鍵分點
這管錢哥
他也是買在這個地方
所以這個都看得很清楚
那這60天來可以看得到
管錢哥買了三萬三千多張
都是管錢哥做的啊
對 做得很好
就是說蕭師傅很坦蕩蕩
沒錯
我們在做籌碼的時候
我們都是從
看看最近有沒有主力連買的標的來找
那可以從這邊的選股可以找得到
選果這邊呢 各位你選官方
官方這裡有多方
多方這裡呢 像這邊可以選主力連買
OK
主力連買 我們可以看到
最近第一名是凱聖
這凱聖是因為被收購了
主力買了一定賺錢了
所以主力買了80天
第二名就是最近很強的
南亞科
我跟你講南亞科也很神奇
雖然這邊不該提另外一個人
谷玉也剛好南亞科
你記得嗎 在節目上
因為他有基本面的支撐
它又有籌碼面的加持
因为南亚科我们看它的籌碼
我们看这籌碼
这60天来里面的大摩
那其中第一名
谭摩跟史丹尼
大摩
不过大摩它不是关键分点
第二名就是关键分点
所以这是外资加上
我们的关键分点
双加持
所以今天特别透露
第二名的关键分点
因为大摩蛮正常
因为南亚科也算全只骨
看好记忆体
就買啊
好
那這第二名關鍵分點呢
給各位看一下
它就是負差
各位看一下
這畫面看得到
它低檔就買很多了
負邦
把它講出來
我認得字啊
我只是照念而已
好
它最近
其實它最近漲上來繼續買
所以看起來記憶體真的很缺
對
很缺啊
這真的很缺
那我們從這籌碼可以看得出來
那這個選股呢
不只可以選多方
像多方裡面
主力連買可以選
还有外资连买 投信连买
Top1的券商买超异常
那空方呢
各位看一下空方
空方有这个主力连卖的
我们来看一下
最近主力连卖 结态
等于是说我不放空我也别碰它了
对啊 结态卖了37天
这看起来好恐怖
见准卖34天
这边都看得很清楚
好 但是重点在
刚刚讲了不见得买最多的会是关键分点有可能是外資 有可能是投信也不見得買最多的分點就叫做關鍵分點
因為它叫關鍵嘛
那一定是過去每一次都非常厲害
它才能叫關鍵
它只是剛好督到啊
剛好跟單啊
那我們不算對不對
我覺得這太難了 我哪知道
所以我們關鍵分點呢
我們有幾個SOP
SOP找出真正的关键分点
第一个
我们会找寻高档大卖的分点
就很厉害
抓到高点卖出
对 高档要卖出
而且要卖很多张
你卖个一张
运气好
我们早都是卖一万八千张
国巨卖在一张
那一张我也是觉得很配
一张我追踪你好累
不知道你什么时候才要再买
我们追踪都是买几万张
卖几万张的
第二个
低档大买的分点
然后第三
我们再找获利的分点
那通常高档有大卖
低档有大买
它就很容易是获利的分点
好
因为它都已经做那么标准了
它一定会赚钱的
对 而且赚很多
赚很多
好 那第四个呢
关键分点我们常常发现
它是地缘分点
刚刚就有讲
我才会问你
是不是在新竹啊
对 路港啊
路港啊 台南啊
甜甜价啊
你還記得
我們那時候講的甜甜架
記得啊
可憲啊
噴出了也噴了
應該來得及啦
沒有噴很多
從他之前的戰績來看
應該還來得及
第五個呢
同級船
常常說就相同分點
像剛剛講的嘛
教師傅
教師傅的
管錢分點
也不想換了
做給你看這真的很棒
好 所以這是SOP
我們利用這個關鍵分點的找法
好 我們來看一下
關鍵分點怎麼找
第一個 台南人來了
高檔大賣 有沒有
真的賣超多 怎麼回事
像瀑布一樣
對啊 低檔大賣 有沒有
有喔 有喔
3D 今年年初3月份的時候
我們最近找關鍵分點
有時候都會找
3月19號你敢大買的
你就是關鍵分點
他厲害在他這波還賣滿兇
他先買可能知道要盤整
他就慢慢買耶
慢慢買 不急咧那擊殺都大買喔擊殺你看上次的低點擊殺大買這個應該就是他那時候廠賣掉大家覺得沒搞頭了那時候外資狂砍
通通接走
你看在這個點也低一點大買
那時候一百七十幾塊
其實如果你用可成這個線來看
這邊不算貴耶對不對
因為他這邊就買了耶
便宜啊我待會再給你看一個東西
再給你看一個東西你就知道這個價格
其實看起來還不算貴
你看
李兆华跟全政小哥
第17集
纠葛
到现在才第19集而已
这段时间你跑去哪了
我没有这段时间我们都在做电视版
然后你都跑去游山玩水教学员
教学
好
这就像您讲的
这一档真的要听台南人的
那时候已经买70几块
各位看一下股价在这里
真的耶
那时候我们讲这个台南人大买
那时候台南大买
然后各位看一下
这个台南人呢
我给各位看一个东西
碰载八国联军
对 我给各位看了
这个资料是十年的资料
2011年啊
一直到今年
因为有筹码显示
是从2011年才开始
所以有筹码以来
所有的资料都在这里
所有资料在这边
那这个里面
最厉害的分点叫
XX北高雄
靠近台南
北高雄就靠近台南
对对对
没错
XX北高雄
各位看一下
他买均价是209.86
那我现在买跟他差不多而已
差不多
他卖均价260.69
现赚5万块一张
对
而且他是买几张
买3万多张
买3万7万
5万2
厉害喔
对啊
而且这中间还有配席
对对对
好歹可诚是有赚钱的公司
这配息都没有算进去
那这个台南人
这个北高雄这个分点
光可诚这十年来赚了28亿
28亿
叔叔我不想努力了
找一下
我要找一下台南的阿姨
对
阿姨我也不想努力
对我不想努力了
台南人我不想努力了
快把我带回去
好那我看一下
这个北高雄是第二名
我们再看底下分点
因為這有些分點它已經都消失了
底下分點第四名XX台南
第五名XX台南第六名XX東門這東門是台北東南還是台南的東門這台南東門插金華插插永康永康也台南啊
插台南插插金鼎台南
欸 大家都知道
大家都知道是哪台南
反正呢
台南人啊 我跟你講
台南人最好待的公司就是可城
嗯
這個以後小朋友栽培他
我就跟他說以後你要記得
你要去可乘上班
對
去可乘上班要幹嘛
打好關係
然後看清楚在哪個分點開個戶
然後也巴結一下營業員
反正裡面
反正台南分點
這些人我們可以都知道
你一定是一堆員工在裡面
對
我是聽說這樣子
是聽說軒跟我講
好
他說他們主委跟他講
最近趕快買趕快買
所以最近都是台南人在買
我們老闆也叫我趕快買房子
也沒錯
今年房地產也很強
你看這台人算一算加起來
賺喔 我們這樣算喔
台人賺可乘這十年來賺超過100億
用可乘在股市提款100億
沒錯 我還沒有算股息喔
還沒有算喔
陳真可乘的高層男友好不好
比較快
可能會在北高雄開戶的那個人
好
所以這邊你有把剛剛講的公布
對不對
XX是什麼
XX
不小心了
這邊忘了遮
可塵在這邊
對
你看厲害的分點在這裡
還有這個X比高雄
好
哇
這分點都是厲害的
這邊都有名字了
然後大家自己看
自己截圖
自己看
對我們就不念了
但是趙華還是不知道啊
我要怎麼統計出來
用手撈嗎
太辛苦了吧
你要利用籌碼K線這個軟體
所以剛剛有提到還是要軟體工具
因為其實籌碼是很麻煩的
籌碼是2011年才公布在網站上讓人家撈
所以我也可以手動統計
我可以做1萬張的Excel表
然後就累死我自己
那統計不出來
太難了
好
所以台南人幫大家賺大錢
我們跟著做就好啦
也不用真的承真什麼男友了
其實看理財達人秀就夠了
就夠了
那我這邊先貼的是我的對賬單
你的對賬單啊
這是我的
不好意思 趙好常常收到
趙好常常收到小哥的對賬單
我真的很想顯示你的財力
讓我覺得很迷戀你對不對
不是
要跟你講說
我們研究籌碼是對的
是
我們後面會有對賬單來
這 酷賞我們
你幹對了
你跟著談人做得很漂亮
所以不要送什麼鮮花
也不要送什麼名牌包
送你一口嗎
送我一口嗎
餵我一口
餵你一口
好 我們現在講可誠
可誠對賬單
我們是這樣子
我有把它分上
對
因为这个避免同一个户头口数太多
万一大跌的时候不好砍
所以把它分散一下
那分散呢
各位看一下
这是我把它分散成三个户头
那这户头呢
20口均价189
小哥你怎么均价那么高
还记得我们是170几讲的吗
对
因为呢
这是12月份的期货
12月咯
其实我们从
我们9月就讲了
对
我们从9月10月11月
一直转仓过来
那么久
对每个月转仓的时候
已经有以食线损益了
那以食线损益我们都不大想去看它
因为这个热热等
所以今天只放了这个一个户头的
以食线
这个不小心空了紧缩赔了10万
不要看不要看
赔钱也贴啦
总不能说这个只讲赚钱
那可能因为这个户头比较干净
这不小心空到井说
不小心用这个户头空
应该这个户头里面只放可乘而已
那可乘光转仓就赚了38万
那这三个户头各位看
这未时间损益今天截除下来
都非常漂亮
其实很多人都说赵华主持
这个理财大人秀
尤其是哥有丑必报
应该自己也赚很多
其实也是有啦
对对对
但是我还没有进入到软体的阶段
对因为我都听你说就好了
直接告诉你答案
直接告诉我
对
好
那这些
这个不止可乘
好
像我们之前讲的
叶辉
你看这我就听你讲的
还记得这一集
记得
我记得你有
因为这档而帮自己加薪
你看看这是我的手
这是你的手
对
是不是很有这种
恋爱feu
对啊
就一起
画一个心这样子
对对对
画一个心
结果当时我有叶辉
你有叶辉
对
心心相应
应该赚蛮多的
对
那時候講說這個大戶增加散戶減股價未反應獨立買超大戶持股比喻增加散戶持股比喻下降那時候才7塊多這個都在軟體都看得到
是
你看到股價跌下來
主力都沒跑
就不用怕了
而且他們真的是低檔
7塊多
現在都已經占回票面
10塊多以上了
你看現在多少
不只占回票面
因為我照花後來賣掉
最高點12塊
7塊到12塊
我就說7塊你怕什麼
這個六七成的獲利
對啊
非常驚人
葉輝耶
鋼鐵骨耶
我不是跟你講小型的腰骨
我們講鋼鐵骨的時候
收視率跌到骨底
對啊
結果莫然回首一看
哇賽
長六七成
對 長那麼多
對
那這些分點
我們證交所得正
其實真的是得正
以前我們要到
這樣要透露年齡了
南海路那裡
南海路
要進去裡面的圖書館
對
你要翻東西嗎?
我是聽人家講的啦
翻老半天
你聽老一輩講的嘛
對對對 我聽老一輩講的
我也聽老一輩有講過
我還沒去過啊
好 現在證教所
哇 你在家裡
對
這個輸入網址啊
這個還要輸入這個
看不大清楚的辨識碼
就辨識碼 這很煩耶
我常按錯
對 很過分
不曉得是一還是
而且有些人還要規定
你大小血要對
那更讓我抓狂
好累好累
那個輸入完之後呢
而且他會給你一串樂樂等的這個
資料
圖表
自己要匯出
做Excel表
對
那每天做這個
太累了
光一檔股票
就61頁
我怎麼做
對
對啊
61頁
太累了
所以我們都會利用
這個籌碼K軟體來看
可是剛剛講籌碼K軟體
如果用手機APP來看
它有局限性
它沒有辦法撈很長的歷史資料
因為你剛剛講說
關鍵分點有時候
我們要觀察10年
2011年公布
他要常常準啊
手機才240天
對 如果他是最近一年準
最近一年誰不準
最近一年很多散戶也很準啊
那不能說他
大家都鼓神了
所以我要怎麼做
就是我要怎樣
我才能撈到更長的資料
來確認他叫關鍵分點
好
這裡呢
我們就用電腦來顯示一下啦
小哥的日常喔
快給我一杯咖啡
我要來看小哥選鼓囉
例如說
可成啊
這10年來
大家真的要珍惜耶
小哥現在在教大家選股
這10年來很簡單
我們用2500天
一年250天就超過了你知道這幾點選股幾點選股 晚上6、六七八点那么早啊应该可以演一下例如在睡前啊就是说小哥你在干嘛
来我帮你按摩你在干嘛
睡前的按摩
我要找明天的那个
明天的标的啊
明天送我的东西啥
对对对
好
那这个可乘呢
找关键分点教你找一下
2500天
对
这个点下去
点下去之后呢
我们再看一个东西
看区间获利
2500天就是所有资料了
对 所有资料
区间获利点出来
我们刚刚讲的
北高雄 台南 东门 金华
刚刚的那张图
永康 台南 都出来了
其实就是刚刚那张图
对 而且他们今天应该赚更多了
因为今天股价又喷出去了
今天我都没跟到
可惜啊
看起来今天是主力买上轨翘
所以还来得及对不对
还来得及啊
刚刚才开始而已
好啦 那小哥你送我一口嘛
送你一口
送你一口可乘
那可乘的關鍵分點
關鍵分點就這樣找
那這軟體呢
你可以看主力買鈔
最近主力轉買鈔了
那外資剛好現在這個籌碼出來
外資大買
那關鍵分點你就可以點了
例如說你點這個
北高雄
哇 他是買這個點的
好厲害喔
這點很漂亮啊
那自己上避險這邊也會顯示
那這邊你還可以看什麼東西啊
你可以看技術指標啊
KD MACD RSI
這邊都可以看
也很方便啦
誰要看技術指標 不用了
這個有的人喜歡看
RSI不用了 不用了
對
那你可以看內部人的持有比率啊
不過你記得看這個是幾%
這8.4 8.5 8.6 8.7
這沒有差多少 沒關係
那最近可乘的大戶啊
各位看一下
大戶慢慢上來囉
是
散戶慢慢掉下來了
這叫做健康
它叫做健康 因為散戶離開了嘛
這個股票上漲
理論上大戶要繼續買
散戶要獲利了結
那這個健康的
假如股票漲上來 散戶來追
這叫做信仰
代表有人鼓吹
不過今年有一段時間散戶是厲害的
但是現在其實又匯到了內置盤
還是要看這些大戶
因為我們很怕股票
這個在高檔的時候少去追啦
那種後面都容易跌下來那這裡你也可以看農資農捐哇 可成融資在減喔那這個可成的借券也在變少券資比是往下
它是券資都往下
可是這時候是不是應該希望
放空它能變多呢
還可以再嘎一下
可能大家都看我們節目啦
我們節目說視率太高了
誰敢空啊
好那就不管它了
對
好 券資比高
你可以看一些比較特別的股票
那我們最喜歡看重碼
我最喜歡看這個主力買超
主力買散戶賣幾保戶數
看這三個指標
最近有一檔股票
瞬間跌很慘喔
來看玉鼎
哇這一瞬間的喔
這就是線圖好不正常
不是跳空漲停
就是跳空跌停
因為這個在左邊的討論區
有人這個鼓吹人家買
那人一買之後一追
各位看一追上來是主力到貨喔
好誇張
主力到貨 然後呢這個散戶大買
幾保戶數從1萬2變成1萬6
都散戶再買 都散戶再上去了
那散戶呢這個上去之後
這個它就容易崩盤 崩下來
那這檔更誇張的
各位你看這邊有個重大事件
重大事件這邊有個申報轉讓
申報轉讓你看
在高檔12月1號
12月1號 哇 這個法恩董事
申報1952張
董監事的申报转让也是一个指标
没错
那申报投资申报1500张
在高档
你看到董事
这法人在卖了
对
那主力又在卖
赶快跑快逃啊
董事在卖我们就要董事了
知道发生事情了
没错
可以从这边看
所以这就是刚刚小哥用电脑的软体
因为电脑可以看过去十年的走势
所以筹码上面到底谁厉害
过去十年谁厉害全部都列出来
小哥有教我们怎么找
对
但是你知道
哥 我不想努力了
你不想努力了
我也不想找
那我把我的
这个今天要送给你的
为什么今天有礼物
有礼物啦
对
这代表我对你的爱心
因为耶诞节要到对不对
而且听说你的生日快到了
12月是赵华月
赵华又要过生日
又有耶诞节
又要跨年
所以你是要约我跨年吗
约我跨年
今天还有跨年
对啊
我沒有幫你抽個號碼牌
現在就是第237號
還好還好
今年行情沒有很熱
好的
好 這個是我今年給你的禮物
什麼禮物
〔此段辨識失敗，約 30:00 起〕